the scholars about this. I know a lot of
people keep telling me this. They're
like, "You're not supposed to study
Islam alone." It's like, "Dude, if I
didn't study it alone, I would never be
here. I would have never reverted." She
keeps talking about scholars. He doesn't
mention one. These scholars, the
scholars, these scholars, these scholars
who brother, yo, you're so weird, but
you books. Tell us one book you have
read. She's not even qualified to read a
book. Let's carry on. Happen. But what I
found to be true is a lot of people
already think this way. They're just too
scared to speak up.
Do not forget to check out cindi.com.
Brothers and sisters, one of my most
amazing clothing brands that I wear,
alhamdulillah, owned by Muslims with the
recent boycott that's going on with many
brands, clothing lines supporting
Israel. Brothers and sisters, you guys
know I've been supporting Cindi.com.
I've been wearing their stuff long, long
time ago. Alhamdulillah. And I love
their clothing, brothers and sisters.
It's exactly what I like, alhamdulillah,
when it comes to fitness training,
jogging, just general wear. When I'm
praying, I don't need to worry about my
back showing. Buy it for your family
members, your your uncles, your
brothers, your husbands, whoever it is.
Inshallah, brothers and sisters, buy it
for yourself, inshallah. It's modest
clothing wear. We're going to get
straight into this reaction video. Uh,
but before we do, alhamdulillah, brother
and sisters, we want to tell you guys
just quickly, quickly, quickly about our
guided prayer mat that we are producing
in 50,000 quantities in five different
languages, Italian, Spanish, Portuguese,
German, and French. And we're going to
be distributing these to DA tables, mos
prisons, and Albanian. And we're going
to be printing sending these to mosques,
da tables, uh prisons. By the way, we've
got a big connection with prisons. Big
connection 150 prisons. I'm ice
inshallah. You can donate in sisters.
100. There's two links there. One for
Sid and below that there will be a link
for this donation. As you guys might
know, I've been wanting to do this video
for a long time. Sh this exatanist.
Okay. Allegedly, allegedly an ex
Satanist who became a Muslim and then
decided to leave the fold of Islam again
by becoming a Quranist. Here's a
reaction we did to this guy because this
guy needs to be warned against. Um, and
there's not only that, he's very
arrogantly coming out and talking about
it. He has no idea what he's talking
about. He said he said that if this is
to be forced on him, he will
leave. You've already you've never came
in to leave. You've given away the
video. Let's hear and hear from Sorry.
Come on. Okay. Let's go.
On how I reverted to Islam, why I came
to this conclusion and what brought me
away from the hadith. And I want to say
ahead of time, if I was forced to follow
hadith, I would just leave the faith
entirely and I would practice the Quran
alone. I genuinely mean that if if the
hadith is forced upon me, I don't want
any part of it. Okay, so just that first
little part there. Um he's basically
saying if you forced me to go back to
the hadith, I will leave Islam. But
there's a bit of a dilemma here. No, but
what he said is even worse. What's that?
I've just heard it properly now. Okay.
He said, "If you force it on me, Yeah. I
would leave the faith, but I will just
practice the Quran."
That's what he said. How's he going? He
said, "I will leave the faith." Yeah,
but I will only practice Quran.
What does that mean? I'm a bit confused.
You're you're already a Quranist. You're
saying if you force me to go back to the
hadith, I will become a Quranist.
I live. No, but it's not that. He said
he he would leave the faith. So, but
he's already left the faith. He's he's
no faith. The funny thing is this now.
Look, he's a disbeliever. He's saying if
you make me want go back to Sunnism, I
will become a kafir. I will already
af I'm not even in the house. But but
the other thing the other thing is that
if you want to leave the faith, why you
want to keep to the Quran?
Let's carry on. to you know you know it
it just shows you the insincerity. It
just shows you that he has got hidden
plans. Exactly. Now I will explain why.
So I reverted to Islam alone in my
bedroom. There was no da there was no
influence. Although I had somebody who's
like an uncle to me who kind of half
reverted while he was in prison. He's
like a mentor to me. I look up to him
quite often. He had spoken about Islam,
spoken about the Quran and kind of tried
to push me in that direction but there
was no like real da. He wasn't really
actually pushing. He just brought it up
a couple times like, "Hey buddy, you
should look this up." This was in the
peak of me being in the middle of the
oult. He just brought it up a couple
times. I am a rever and I was taught how
to pray salah. That means every single
time I pray, the person who told me gets
the reward five times a day from to Isa.
If you want to support someone like me
in learning salah, then sponsor 10
people for just £100 this Ramadan.
Remember the prophet peace be upon him
said, "Charity does not decrease
wealth." Click the button and donate
now.
Okay. Fantastic. So, he's just basically
indirect power um from his uncle who was
in prison. But yeah, apparently took his
shahada on his own. But one thing I do
find a bit bizarre, I've not seen a
single video of him talking about how he
came to Islam. Like, but did you hear
what he said? You have to listen to what
he said. He said he said half converted.
Oh, about the uncle in Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I know. I heard that. He said he
was my half converted kind of like half
converted. What's this half converted?
Yeah, I don't know why he's calling his
uncle half converted because he's half
converted as well. The Torah and picked
up the Quran at the exact same time. As
I studied that faith that I won't
mention on here, it got worse and worse.
I I just kept seeing more flaws within
the rhetoric, more contradictions, more
issues, and above all else, serious
moral issues in the faith. Now, on the
other hand, the more I studied the
Islamic faith, the better it got. The
more I studied the Quran, the more I got
attached to it. And then the first time
I heard the Quran in Arabic, it touched
me and changed my life forever. So my
loyalty initially was with the Quran,
was with the word of God, the thing that
is flawless, has no mistakes. And this
is what brought me to the faith and got
me to the point where I was defending it
endlessly immediately because I knew
this was the word of God. I know this
came from God. There was no doubt in my
mind that the Quran really is from
Allah. Now, the first time I started
doubting the hadith, it was before I
even studied it, which I will admit
isn't really fair, right? Having doubts
in something that you haven't looked at.
So, one second. So, you he admits that
he started having doubts about the
hadith without even studying it. Now,
there's two things we need to mention. I
knew the Quran was from God. Okay. Based
on what evidence like like it's good.
You need you need to know. He makes two
claims. I accepted the Quran, knew it
was from God. No shadow of a doubt.
Okay. But how? I studied for about good
3 years. Secondly, I rejected the hadith
and I didn't study it. So both of them,
you're accepting one without studying it
and rejecting one without studying it.
Without studying it, it's it's like
you're just jumping. Very weird.
Anything work out? No, it just it just
kind of like it's full of confusion.
It's full of confusion and controversy.
Yeah. You should always study something
before you doubt it. But this came
through an argument on Twitter, right? a
dumb silly ex or Twitter argument with
people that were just attacking me left
and right using crazy wild hadith
quotes. And it got to the point where I
just kept telling them like, "Show me in
the Quran where it says these things.
Show me in the Quran where it
disrespects the prophets. These hadith
that they were referring to was very,
very disrespectful to the prophets." And
I know Islam does not do anything to
disrespect them. So this was extremely
contradictive. And it just got me to the
point where my whole defense was, "Show
me in the Quran. Don't show me some like
hadith that I don't even know, some wild
hadith. And this is because the Quran
says multiple times that it is fully
explained. We'll break down verses and
contradictions and things in a little
bit, but right now I kind of want to
focus on how I started to get to this
direction just in case you're on the
same path or you know somebody in a
similar direction. Maybe you can
convince them of your ways or Okay, we
get the gist. So this is where anytime
I've spoken to Quranist, I always tell
them I'll go let me get this before you
speak. the promised marriage to Aisha.
Aisha was 18, she wasn't six. Okay. The
capital punishment for adulterers, you
don't believe it exists. Um capital
punishment for mortad apostates. You
don't believe exists. He goes, "Yeah,
you see a pattern." And he's just
admitted, you know, when he was talking
about the hadith disrespect and yes, the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam that
was the marriage to No. When he means
disrespect, remember was asking him what
do you mean by disrespect? He's talking
about for example the prophet married
Aisha 6. He thinks that's disrespectful
to the prophet to the prophet. The
prophetam said a capital punishment of
the prophet that's disrespectful to the
prophet. He's basically saying with his
limited liberal thinking, he's making a
judgment and saying, "Oh, that's
disrespectful to." And because I didn't
have an answer, I would tell them, "Show
me in the Quran. Show me in the Quran."
It already shows that you had an
inferiority complex. And if we go to
Maida verse 54, if you read it, Allah
talks about those who live their fa
leave their faith become a mut like you.
By the way, like you, Allah will replace
them with people who are humble, who
love Allah, and Allah loves them and
they do not. This is very key. Allah is
talking about the psychology of people
like you. mut yeah that they do not care
about the blame blamers who blame blame
meaning that you don't they don't have
an infur complex subhan Allah and the
example for this what Abu Bakr said when
the mush king came to him and said your
companion says he flew to the heavens
come and say that's not true I don't
think he would say that no where did you
get this from let me go and ask him what
did he say she he said did he say it
that's so profound you know what that
means I just want to know did that come
out his mouth Absolutely. And once they
said yes, what did he say? Did he say
no, no, no, no, I I believe it. He said
it is this is
look at the contrast. Allah talks about
the psychology of the mut and Allah
talks about the the psychology of the
Subhan Allah because in the Quran what's
it come after the prophet?
Exactly. Subhan Allah. So it shows you
the best of the best and the worst of
the worst is MTA. Subhan Allah.
Absolutely. Yes. And that shows me that
you're the inference complex. Sorry, Ju
just quickly quickly. Do you hear him
what he say? This is for people that are
on the same path.
So you you know there is a hidden agenda
in there. There's a hidden agenda in
there. It's good you pick up on that
we're being referenced was pretty bad.
It was pretty brutal. They were calling
the prophets some names that I'm not
going to ever repeat. But all in all,
that argument kind of did open my eyes a
little bit and I started to study hadith
a little bit more. And then that's when
the division came in. Now, since
reverting, everybody has tried to push
on me to decide Sunni or Shia so many
different times, and I never wanted
anything to do with it. I don't want
anything to do with the division. Now, I
know coming out and speaking about this
and my beliefs against the hadith is
going to cause a bit of division, but I
just have to bite the bullet. I don't
understand. I don't want to cause
division, but I'm going to cause
division and I'm going to bite the
bullet. But look, Kaban, you you you
reverted to Islam. Yeah. Did anybody
come and said, "Oh, by the way, you have
to choose Sunnis and all." Did someone
come did any do you know of anybody who
who reverted to Islam by your help? Did
you pose this question to them? No,
never. So why is he saying people were
coming to me telling me, "Oh, you have
to choose between Shiaism and Sunnism."
I don't know. And not only that, she
like we spoke about it like his dark
black hat, black dyed hair, black dog,
black dog, inverted camera.
Let's think about this guy. This is
because I've felt like it's been
inauthentic the entire time that I
haven't said anything to you guys. I've
kind of blown off collabs with Sneo and
some other really big content creators
because I just didn't feel like it was
right. It wasn't fair. It wouldn't be
cool if they would have me on their
platform. I get all these positive
benefits whenever I don't actually align
with the same beliefs as them. I found
that very disingenuine. So, I did kind
of blow off all these collabs and
ignored them. And what I should have
done is spoke about this sooner. I
should have just told everybody from the
beginning, I'm having doubt about the
hadith. I'm not certain quite yet.
There's more stuff I'm studying. The
more I'm learning about hadith, the
worse it gets for me, the more it pushes
me away from the faith. Now, on top of
that, every time I get attacked from
inside the community, it's people who
follow the Hadith and follow it to a
point where they put it above the Quran.
I've been told multiple times that the
Quran needs the Hadith. This is
completely contradictive. The Quran is
fully explained. It is telling us this
in many different verses. Okay? So, he's
saying the more I was studying hadith,
the more it got worse for me. My friend,
you are not qualified to study hadith.
Absolutely. What are you talking about,
man? It's like me. It's like me coming
and saying, "Yeah, I'm going to go and
study the Boeing 747." And what the hell
are you talking about, man? You study
what you're basically saying. He's
basically saying, "The more I read
hadith, it's getting more problematic
for me." Meaning, you cannot deal with
certain truths, you don't have an
understanding, you haven't looked at it
comprehensively to understand because
I've spoken to non-Muslim sheh who I've
explained the marriage to prophet Aah.
The video is up. It's got three or 400
400,000 views where the guy comes and
says that makes perfect sense. Look,
there is an orientalist called Nabi
Abbot. Yeah, Nabia Abbot. An
orientalist. She speaks highly of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam. An
orientalist of all people, you know,
pmicist kind of she she has no love for
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
or for Islam, you know, but she speaks
good about it. But you know, he has he
has got a hidden agenda in her because
and let me add one thing quickly,
please. You know what what it is? Tell
him to name the books that he has read
on hadith. There are hardly any books on
hadith on hadith that aren't translated
into English. Exactly. And he can't even
speak Arabic. Yeah. When one person says
he does, no, it doesn't. Now, I know a
lot of people are just going to be like,
well, how do you pray? To me, that
doesn't really sit very well. One,
because the Quran does explain this very
well. Later, I'll make a video
explaining how I pray without hadith and
go over all the different issues that
people have with this. I'm okay with
explaining myself. I came to this
conclusion through research and studies
over a long period of time. I didn't
just come up with this yesterday. One
long periods of time, man. You've been a
Muslim yesterday. What are you talking
about? Somebody will think he's been a
Muslim for 25 years. And he's talking
about praying, my friend. You don't have
a kibra direction. You don't even know
how to do wudoo. You don't even know how
to do ablution. You don't you can't even
pray without that hadith. A lot of
people who do hold the hadith above the
Quran. And this isn't right. This isn't
fair. We should never ever ever be
holding the word of man. Even though you
may believe it's the word of the
prophet, that's okay. Everybody has
their own path. But even if it is the
teachings of the prophet, it is not the
word of God. We cannot hold the hadith
above the Quran at all. Uh okay. Sure.
So now he's like it is wrong to take the
saying of a man or what does he say
someone over the
Do we do we do do we believe this? No,
we don't believe it. Okay. You know,
Subhan
Allah. Subhan Allah. the the the saying
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. Now these people so what it
means apart from the Quran everything
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said is a lie if you come to
think about it yeah exactly because the
speech of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam his normal dealing in that
that's the hadith exactly so let's think
about this guy in the time of the
prophetam the prophetam says this ayah
was revealed to me and the meaning and
how we incorporate it is this he would
have to say the prophetam say no I'm not
going to take your word over the Quran
over the Quran yeah this is I don't
understand like what part of your brain
is missing. By the way, I done a I done
I done a debate yesterday.
That's that's that's already I heard. I
heard that's already come out. Check
that video inshallah guys and uh enjoy
that in cuz we actually deal with the
situation in person. Subhan Allah. And
we're breaking our fast in. Let's carry
on. That made me kind of not have a good
feeling about it. Now before I continue,
now I'm about to start explaining Quran
verses and contradictions within the
hadith that really make me not want to
follow it. One of them being Aisha's
age. There is a pretty significant issue
within that one or at least a couple
issues. But I want everybody to know I'm
not here to convince anybody of
anything. What you follow is what you
follow. You could be Christian, you can
be a cultist. I don't care. How you pray
is none of my business. What you pray to
doesn't affect me. I'm just here
explaining my experiences and my
beliefs. And this is also due to I don't
want there any confusion in the future.
I don't want to feel like I'm misleading
anybody based on my own selfidentity. I
don't want to believe like I'm telling
people or putting up some image and I'm
actually living this way. I I don't want
to separate that. It's a miserable place
to be. I just don't want to be
disingenuine to anybody. So, I need to
come out and be fully clean and
transparent about this. Now, I have a
couple verses pulled up. I will pop them
up on screen as well. I know some people
are going to argue that the
translation's wrong. I've gone through
this very deeply and I've pulled up
multiple translations. There's tons of
very good websites that translate
Arabic. And I look at all the different
translations through multiple different
scholars. And what I do is I take the
truth as the center. I look at all these
translations and I see what is the
consistency between every single one of
them. And that's what I base this off
of. So it's not just like picking one or
the other. I look at all of them and
then I take this. So she Yeah, it's very
bizarre. He's now basically it's like
he's talking like he's a scholar. He has
the tools. She How many sciences do you
have to be involved? to go to an ayah,
take it, break it down, come to the
truth. This man is talking like the mi
he's like
the like he's become the mut of our the
the the scholars they have they have
limited it in about 22 sciences sciences
you need to know the the the Arabic the
the poetry uh the s of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
wasallam uh half of the Quran half of
the
Quran They're
Sheckh. I've been a Muslim for 11 years.
I don't think I have anywhere near that.
Forget one side is this man who's been a
Muslim probably a year or less than a
year. He's saying I go to the Qurans, I
break it down and I look for the truth.
You have to be in delusion. Absolutely.
Either you're in delusion or you got a
gene inside you. Look, there's something
the latter the latter I think the latter
is correct. It has to be cuz you was an
exatanist. You need to my friend you
should when you come to Islam you're
coming with you was a magician and this
that brother you don't know what baggage
you come with you need to detox yourself
brother I when I came to Islam I came
with bad traits I had to cleanse myself
and get rid of them it took me years
absolutely brother you come with magic
jin Satan witchcraft he needs a digital
yeah subh and you come here now the
first one is chapter 11 verse verse the
first verse in the 11th chapter explains
this. And this was the first verse,
ironically, that really stood out to me
that kind of pushed me in this direction
as well. And I'll pull up the exact
thing that I'm referencing, but
essentially what it says is that the
book is fully perfected. That the Quran
is in perfect detail. In other words,
fully explained. Now this was weird to
me because it's like okay if the word of
God is fully explained meaning it
doesn't need any explanation what is the
purpose of hadith and a lot of the
people every time I've heard they've
always just told me the hadith explains
how or explains this or explains why and
it's an explanation or a teaching to the
Quran but that doesn't make any sense
when the Quran is saying it's fully
explained.
Yeah. Okay. What's your answer to this?
No. Explained meaning that it's
explained from. But who did Allah
explained it to?
You see what I mean? Okay. Yeah, we
agree with you is and it's explained.
Yes. Now,
who from? Yes. All wise, all aware.
Yeah. This all wise all aware. Who did
he explain the Quran to?
Um, it should be the messenger. No. I I
I I should think so. So, what does it
mean? So, how did the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is going to relate to us
the explanation? He just shot himself in
the foot. Let's carry on with scholars
about this. I know a lot of people keep
telling me this. They're like, "You're
not supposed to study Islam alone." It's
like, "Dude, if I didn't study it alone,
I would never be here. I would have
never reverted." She keeps talking about
scholars. He doesn't mention one.
Discolors, discolors, discolor who
brother, yo, you're so weird. Books,
books. Tell us one book you have read.
She's not even qualified to read the
book. Let's carry on. Happen. But what I
found to be true is a lot of people
already think this way. They're just too
scared to speak up. And that is another
one of my concerns. It's like I found
there's a lot of people, and I'm telling
you, a lot more people than a lot of you
guys realize that don't like the hadith.
And even people who talk about it
publicly don't follow it at all. And a
lot of these massive DAWA pages were in
my DMs telling me I'm on the right path,
that this is correct. Now, these are
people that people perceive to be like
Sunni and Shia and follow these certain
sectors of hadith. They agree with me.
They just can't speak up. Brother, I
don't know what Dan is talking about. I
just want to make a lot of people. It
was not me and I don't think anyone that
I know with the right mind would ever
endorse this guy. Apparently Daw channel
is endorsing him and saying yeah we want
to but few are but look what he said he
said more than you can think meaning
like we have got Quran is more than you
can think nice conspiracy. Yeah my
friend please you're the only last bit
of this I'm going to go over the hadith
about Aisha's age because this one I
find extremely disrespectful and the
main reason why the hadith causes major
issues for the faith in the Quran. When
you speak to people when you speak to
Christians they're always going to call
the prophet outside of his name. They're
always going to call him a certain name
that I'm not going to repeat. And they
do it because of this hadith. You guys
all know what I'm talking about. This
hadith actually contradicts the Quran.
And I have mixed how does the hadith
contradicts the Quran. Okay. The hadith
of the marriage of how does he's going
to say it says
yeah don't know the thing is when he
says contradiction. You know what he's
talking about? He's saying I cannot
accept the fact that she was six. And
this is where it goes back to Quran has
become Quran is because of this. They
cannot accept the hadith and what it
says. So they're like, "Oh, how do we
get out of this? We don't want to leave
Islam. I know the only way is we reject
Hadith. It's an inferiority complex. How
are you saying this contradicting the
Quran?" And even that if we took the
hadith out, if you go to the Quran on
its own, it can even be understood. You
know, there's not even an age when it
comes to marriage. If Do you get what
I'm trying to say? Yes. It's actually
from your standard, it becomes worse if
you just went to the Quran and know
hadith. So are you going to leave the
Quran now because to your standard is
watch and I know he's going to watch
this video by the way your standard is
what the pro marriage Aisha mentioned
the hadith six consummated at 9 when she
became a woman an adult you're saying
now she herself said that in Bkari
exactly now he's saying I'm going to go
to the Quran only now when you go to the
Quran only without the explanation of
hadith there is no age of when it comes
to marriage and and according to the and
the verse of Quran that he mentioned the
verse of Quran he mentioned is is a
witness over him. Yes. Exactly. Because
it said explained whom to whom Allah jaw
in the Quran. Exactly. There you go. So
you should now you're going to have to
read the Quran to your standard cuz your
moral argument is it consequentially
wrong. Is it categorically wrong? What
is your evidence your liberal world view
worldview looking into it? Satanic
satanic view not liberal on people who
defend it. Now, I was one of these
people at one point in time where I
would say that the age is just
misinterpreted that the age is actually
about 10 years older. And there is
something to back that up. Sure. But
above all else, it contradicts the
Quran. So, from what I've been taught,
from what I've seen, if a hadith
contradicts the Quran, it is invalid.
And so, if it contradicts the Quran, why
are people supporting this hadith? That
makes me really nervous. Exactly. There
you go. Look, you just expose yourself.
Yes. Okay. You go. He goes, I used to be
those people who used to say what? No,
Aisha is 10 years older. Older? Yeah,
for some reason she's 18. Fits the
legal. For some odd reason, they could
have been. They don't say she was 12 or
13. For some reason, it's 18. Bang on
point with the legal age apparently.
Yeah. So, again, it depends though cuz
in the UK is 16. In France is 15. In
America, it's 13. Marriage is not 16 in
here. No, no, no. Here to have intimacy.
Intimacy is 16. But marriage you have to
be older. No, I know exactly. But you
can have sex in there. Okay. 16. France
15. America 12, 13, and 14. 14 according
to according to your standard then uh
anything below 18 they're pedophiles so
your argument doesn't work and again it
shows what you was on the verge already
like Allah says in the Quran those who
worship Allah on the edge you already
had inferiority complex you were saying
oh no she was 18 years old this proves
you had you had the inferiority complex
you was in shaky grounds already that's
why you went to become a Quranist and
here is the last reaction video and the
journalis have done over this guy the
big one I'm going to point at is chapter
33:32 2 where it refers to Aisha as
woman, not girl. This is a serious
contradiction because a 6 or 9year-old
is not a woman. Some people want to
pretend like they can reach puberty at
this age, but it is next to zero.
There's like a next to 0% chance. I get
it. It's Aisha we're talking about, so,
you know, there's always going to be
exceptions, but a six-year-old has not
reached puberty by the Quran standards
or anybody else's standards. Like I
said, the other contradictions back this
up, but this is the main one for me. And
this verse said, "You are not like any
other woman." Now, I'm going to
mispronounce this most likely, but it
uses Nissa. I can understand a decent
amount of Arabic. I just don't ever try
to speak it. So, the way I read it in my
head is probably wrong, but you guys
understand what I'm saying. It's saying
Nissa, meaning woman. It refers to Aisha
as a woman, and it never refers to her
as a girl. A six-year-old is a girl. A
six-year-old is not a woman. But do you
see what's happening? Ali first of all
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
didn't marry her when she was nine. When
she was six
he there was a betroin. Yes. And then
the the the nikah was consummated at the
age of nine. When she became an adult
when she became an adult. In Islam we
have got two things a girl and a and a
woman. A boy and a man. Yes. We don't
have got these things on in between and
that once a woman once a girl
reaches has got minces that's it she
moves to uh like also there has to be
like the harm factor like for example
mentally sexually and physically ready.
We're not saying as soon as she gets her
messes, she's ready for marriage or
intimacy and she has to be physically
and emotionally. Exactly. Cuz like in
this country, in the UK, when a girl
reaches the age of 16, she can have
intimacy, but she might not be actually
ready physically. Physically, she might
not be ready. But the law says she can.
And that's why Islam doesn't say one
shoe fits all. It caters for each
individual situation. And this is where
you can see the fact that you keep
mentioning Aisha's marriage. You are
just an insecure man who couldn't deal
with the reality. You wanted to um um uh
bow down to the liberal worldview and
the western values and that's what you
find. He even said this the main thing
for me. Exactly. That's why you can
Quranist William Blackstone's book on
British common law in the 1900s at the
age of seven girls need to be matured in
this country let alone 1400 years ago
and he says this is an impossibility for
a woman to mature. There was a situation
a a case study uh that happened I don't
know which year a five or six year old
girl she was actually she was great
raped. Yeah. And she became pregnant.
She gave birth. Yeah. And this is
abhorrent. This is wrong. in Islam
doesn't f but it shows that she could
conceive but again it was harmful to her
so when he's talking about she cannot be
a woman yes we we say even
scientifically when a woman conceives it
when a woman on a period it shows that
she is ready to conceive however Islam
protects a woman and says no just
because that can happen doesn't mean you
can have intimacy yeah which is the the
hadith of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
exactly by anybody's standards there's
no six-year-old that has reached
maturity so not Not only is this
extremely disrespectful to the prophet,
this is extremely disrespectful to Aisha
as well. This is the main thing that
drives a wedge between Islam and the
rest of the world. This exact hadith and
this hadith has multiple contradictions.
There's some pretty good videos on
YouTube. You guys can pull it up. These
guys have explained it in better detail
than I can myself. I just have some
cliff notes to work off of just to bring
to you guys so you guys understand where
I'm coming from and my perspective on
things. Anyways guys, in a nutshell, you
get it. He's just inferior. He has an
inferiority complex. He's insecure. 54
clearly explains man's psychology. And
he said the thing that has a wedge
between the western world and Islam is
this hadith. And it's basically saying
you have to fit your into the western
world norms. My friend, who told you
that's a yastic? Where can you can you
prove to me? How can you prove to me
that our yastic is a liberal worldview
and their and their standards? Get the
hell out of here, man. With a hedenistic
world. He did not he did not mention one
single book, one single scholar, one
single
channel, nothing. He mentioned the
brother Sneo and says that he's avoiding
them. Well, he's avoiding him for a good
reason, isn't it? Exactly. Of course,
100%. I mean, I'm going to I'm going to
do a video with Sneo in in in Mecca.
Inshallah. Let them know she We're going
to we're building up now cuz it's going
to be we're going to the Holy Lands in
Guys, we got a big surprise for you
guys. Let's go.
Okay, that's
it. Before the video, one last tell them
about our salah project, guys. We've got
one salah instructor. We've got guided
mats 50,000 in Italian, French, German,
Spanish, Portuguese, and Albanian. We're
distributing them to da tables, mosques,
prisons, ice inshallah. And not only
that, we've got salah hubs opening all
across UK and Europe. And lastly, our
salah coming really soon. Donate in the
link in check out sindeed.com. Use my
discount code with them and also donate
for this.